have you guys seen the fan art no have
you survived sure sometimes what you
showed that but there's other ones like
this is nice is that what you were
reading this is how you might know and
what if what if you're at the craft
services drink filming one of them gets
hungry what you could share a cherry
cupcakes what do you what are you
wearing James in there it's a shoemaker
yes you put the baking and I'm feeding
you yeah you could work hard all
afternoon James so you deserve a treat
so I'm taking your cherry yes meanwhile
after filming you're just relaxing don't
do this I know it's tough being number 9
but here you are baking it's rather
beautiful now for some reason
wait a minute stop everything for the
minute meal whoever's creating this
artwork I applaud your artistry by the
way you for what but if anybody's given
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but James looks incredibly likes ooh
lolly here I also look a bit like that's
that's like that's looks no it looks
like what you're saying is if anybody's
doing the killing its me I'm thank you
looks like it looks like a couple we've
been together for 25 years and they're
like you know I'd sex a long time come
on let's try what they do is they've got
these various scenarios they dream up
for you what you do is if you go to the
fan fiction websites alright and when I
say panfish websites
this is nuts some of these stories are
250,000 words long that's like two books
yeah okay so what they do is they
summarize them so here is it one so
here's what every Weinstein option them
pretty sure so here's one like Michael
Fassbender is a powerful man with
powerful enemies he asked the agency for
the best they had they sent him James
[Applause]
okay I'm just trying to stay away from
this as far as for you you go with first
one there huh
after finding out James is pregnant with
twins
[Applause]
[Music]
James and Michael start to learn how to
balance upcoming Parenthood and their
careers with help from friends and
families they are sweeter creepy but
sweet James and Michael decide to knit
scarves for each other
James is very good at it but Michael
ends up with something that is
definitely not a scar Michael like
certain kinks in bed
roleplay and costumes and scenes I
thought it was saying scones it and
before but this time this night he's
tired he feels a bit ridiculous in the
outfit and he wants Michael to want him
as himself for once
[Applause]
[Music]
the first day of x-men origins I read
naked I seem to quite enjoy it really
some very freeing feeling take your
clothes off it's wonderful should we do
it
[Applause]